J’adore les arbres, et j'ai beaucoup de chance
car nous vivons à côté d'un magnifique arboretum,
et souvent le dimanche j'y vais avec ma femme
et maintenant, avec mon petit de quatre ans
on grimpe aux arbres et on joue à cache-cache.
Et la deuxième école où j'allais avait de grands arbres aussi.
Elle avait un fantastique tulipier, je pense que c'était le plus grand du pays,
et il y avait aussi beaucoup de superbes buissons et de la végétation
tout autour, autour des terrains de jeux.
Et un jour des camarades de classe m'ont attrapé,
et jeté dans les buissons, j'ai été dépouillé, j'ai été attaqué,
j'ai été insulté, et c’est venu de nulle part.
La raison pour laquelle je dis ça, c'est parce que, après, j'ai pensé --
donc, je suis retourné à l'école, je me suis senti sale, trahi
j'avais honte, mais surtout -- je me sentais surtout impuissant,
et 30 ans plus tard j'étais assis dans un avion
à côté d'une femme, Veronica, qui venait du Chili
et nous étions en tournée pour les droits de l'homme
et elle a commencé à me raconter ce que ça faisait d'être torturée,
et, de ma place très privilégiée,
c'était ma seule référence sur la question.
Et c'était une expérience de vie extraordinaire
parce que pour moi, les droits de l'homme n'avaient qu'un intérêt partiel,
vou voyez, mais surtout,
c'était quelque chose qui arrivait aux autres, là-bas..
Mais j'ai reçu un appel de Bono en 1985 et, comme vous le savez,
c'est un grand chanteur, mais c'est un sacré manipulateur, et --
(Rires)
c'est quelqu'un à qui il est difficile de dire non, et il disait
c'était juste après que j'ai fait fait la chanson Biko,
nous allons faire une tournée pour Amnesty.
tu dois en faire partie, et, vraiment, c'était la première fois
que je rencontrais des personnes
qui avaient vu leur famille se faire tuer sous leurs yeux,
et un proche jeté d'un avion dans l'océan,
et soudain, ce monde des droits de l'homme est entré dans mon monde,
et je ne pouvais vraiment plus m'en aller comme si de rien n'était.
Et donc je me suis impliqué dans cette tournée, qui était pour Amnesty,
et, puis, en '88, j'ai repris le travail de Bono en essayant d'apprendre à convaincre.
Je n'ai pas aussi bien réussi, mais nous avons quand même obtenu Youssou N'Dour, Sting
Tracy Chapman, et Bruce Springsteen pour faire le tour du monde pour Amnesty,
et ce fut une expérience extraordinaire.
Et, une fois encore, j'ai eu une expérience de vie incroyable,
et c'était la première fois, vraiment,
que je rencontrais autant de ces personnes dans les différents pays
et ces histoires de droits de l'homme sont devenues très concrètes,
et, là encore, je ne pouvais plus faire comme si de rien n'était.
Mais ce qui m'a vraiment surpris, ce dont je n'avais aucune idée
c'était qu'on puisse souffrir comme ça
et, qu'après, tout ce qu'on a vécu, votre histoire, soit nié
enterré et oublié.
Et il semblait que dès qu'un appareil photo était présent
ou une vidéo ou caméra vidéo,
c'était beaucoup plus difficile pour ceux qui étaient au pouvoir d'enterrer l'histoire .
Et Reebok a créé une fondation après cette tournée des droits de l'homme
et une décision a été prise --
et nous avons fait une proposition, pendant quelques années,
pour tenter de créer une filiale
qui allait donner des appareils photos aux militants des droits de l'homme.
Ca n'a pas donné grand chose
et puis il y a eu l'incident Rodney King, et les gens ont pensé,
Bon, si on a une caméra au bon endroit au bon moment,
ou, peut-être, au mauvais moment, suivant le point de vue qu'on a,
alors, on peut vraiment commencer à faire quelque chose.
et à militer, et à être entendu,
et à informer les gens de ce qu’il se passe.
Donc « Witness » a été créé en '92
et a, depuis, distribué des caméras dans plus de 60 pays.
Et nous militons avec des groupes d'activistes,
et les aidons à raconter leurs histoires, et, en fait,
dans un instant je vais vous montrer une des campagnes les plus récentes,
et j'ai peur que ce soit une histoire d'Ouganda,
et bien qu'hier nous ayons eu une histoire merveilleuse d'Ouganda
celle-ci n'est pas tout à fait aussi bonne.
Et, dans le nord de l'Ouganda,
il y a quelque chose comme un million et demi de personnes déplacées au sein du pays,
des personnes qui ne sont pas des réfugiés d’autres pays,
mais à cause de la guerre civile qui dure depuis environ 20 ans,
ils n’ont nulle part où vivre.
Et 20000 enfants ont été enlevés pour devenir des enfants-soldats,
et la cour criminelle internationale est en train de poursuivre cinq des chefs de –
comment ça s’appelle ?
J’ai oublié le nom de – de l’armée,
c’est la Lord’s Resistance Army je crois… –
mais le gouvernement n’est pas innocent non plus
donc nous allons lancer la première vidéo.
(Musique)
Femme : La live dans le camp n'est jamais simple. Même aujourd'hui la vie est difficile
Nous restons parce que la peur qui nous a poussée dans ce camp...
existe toujours là-bas chez nous.
Texte: "Pris entre deux feux: Torture et Déplacement en Ouganda du Nord"
Homme: Quand nous étions chez nous, c'était les soldats rebelles de Kony qui nous dérangeaient.
Au début, on était en sécurité dans le camp.
Mais ensuite les soldats du gouvernement on commencé à nous maltraiter largement.
(Chants)
Jennifer: Un soldat s'est avancé sur la route en nous demandant d'où on venait.
Evelyn et moi nous nous sommes cachées derrière ma mère.
Evelyn: Il nous a donné l'ordre de nous assoir, alors on s'est assises.
L'autre soldat est venu aussi.
Jennifer: L'homme est venu et a commencé à me déshabiller.
L'autre a emmené Evelyn à l'écart.
Celui qui m'a souillée m'a laissée ensuite pour aller violer Evelyn.
Et celui qui violait Evelyn est venu me souiller aussi.
Homme: Les soldats nous battent avec des gourdins longs comme ça pour nous faire avouer.
Ils nous répètent: "Dis la vérité!" tout en nous frappant.
Femme: Ils répétaient que je mentais.
A ce moment là, ils ont tiré et ont sectionné mes doigts.
Je suis tombée. Ils ont couru rejoindre les autres ... en me laissant pour morte.
(Musique)
Texte: L'Ouganda a ratifé la convention contre la torture en 1986.
La torture est définie comme un acte par lequel une douleur sévère
qu'elle soit physique ou mentale
est intentionnellement infligée par une personne agissant de manière officielle
pour obtenir des informations ou une confession, pour punir, contraindre ou intimider.
Donc, la torture n'arrive pas toujours qu'ailleurs.
Dans mon pays,
nous avions regardé des images de soldats britanniques passant à tabac de jeunes Irakiens,
Nous avons Abou Ghraib, nous avons Guantanamo Bay
et j'avais un chauffeur en allant à l'aéroport de Newark
et il m'a raconté une histoire : au milieu de la nuit, 4 heures du matin,
il a été sorti de force de sa maison dans le Queens – emmené quelque part dans le Midwest,
où il a été interrogé et torturé,
et remis à la rue, quatre semaines plus tard,
parce qu'il avait le même nom, (il était originaire du moyen orient)
et il avait le même nom que l'un des pilotes du 11 septembre,
et cela peut être vrai ou pas,
mais je ne pense pas qu'il m’ait menti.
Et je pense que, si nous regardons dans le monde,
à l’image de la fonte des calottes glaciaires polaires,
les droits de l'homme, pour lesquels on s’est battu,
parfois pendant plusieurs centaines d'années,
s’effritent également très rapidement,
et c'est une chose à laquelle il faut qu’on s’intéresse
et peut-être, pour laquelle il faut militer.
Je veux dire ici également que l’un de nos partenaires était chez Van Jones
et le projet Books Not Bars, ils ont réussi
avec leurs images - en Californie,
à changer le système correctionnel des jeunes détenus,
et je pense que ce sont des méthodes bien plus humaines
qui sont envisagées, pour l'emprisonnement des jeunes.
et c'est discutable en soi,
et comme l’histoire de Mr. Morales juste au bout de la rue :
- Excusez-moi, Mr Gabriel,
cela vous dérangerait si nous retardions légèrement votre exécution ?
- Non pas du tout, sans problème, prenez votre temps. »
Mais cela, qui que soit cet homme, quoiqu’il ait fait,
ceci est une punition cruelle et inhabituelle.
Quoi qu'il en soit, WITNESS a tenté d'armer les gens courageux,
qui mettent souvent leurs vies en danger, partout dans le monde, avec des caméras,
et je voudrais vous en montrer un peu plus. Merci.
(Tonnerre)
(Musique)
Texte: Vous pouvez dire qu'un jury est corrompu.
Vous pouvez dire qu'une personne ment.
Vous pouvez dire que vous ne faites pas confiance aux journaux.
Mais vous ne pouvez pas dire
que ce que vous venez de voir
n'est jamais arrivé.
Aidez WITNESS à donner des caméras au monde.
Filmez une vidéo,
exposez l'injustice,
révélez la vérité,
montrez-nous ce qui ne va pas dans le monde
et peut-être
que nous pourrons
vous aider
à y remédier
WITNESS.
Toutes les vidéos que vous venez de voir ont été filmées
par des groupes de défense des droits de l'homme qui travaillent avec WITNESS
(Applaudissements)
PG: WITNESS est né de l’innovation technologique,
dans le sens où la petite caméra portative numérique
est vraiment ce qui nous a permis d’exister.
Et nous essayons aussi de donner des ordinateurs au monde,
de sorte que les groupes puissent communiquer beaucoup plus efficacement,
faire campagne plus efficacement ;
mais, à présent, nous avons une merveilleuse possibilité,
grâce au téléphone portable avec caméra intégrée,
c’est bon marché, c’est très répandu, et ça évolue rapidement
partout dans le monde, et c’est très excitant pour nous.
Et donc, le rêve serait de vivre dans un monde
où toute personne à qui il arrive quelque chose de mal, de ce genre,
ait une chance de voir son histoire téléchargée,
vue, regardée,
qu'ils sachent vraiment qu'ils peuvent être entendus,
qu'il pourrait alors y avoir un site Web géant,
peut-être un peu comme Google Earth,
et vous pourriez le survoler et découvrir la réalité de ce qui se passe
pour les habitants du monde, en un sens –
ce que cette technologie permet est – vraiment,
que beaucoup des problèmes du monde aient un visage humain,
que nous puissions réellement, voir qui est en train de mourir du SIDA,
ou qui est battu, pour la première fois,
et nous puissions entendre les histoires grâce à la blogosphère -
si nous pouvons avancer sur ces terrains-là,
je pense que nous pouvons, vraiment, transformer le monde de nombreuses manières,
Il pourrait y avoir un nouveau mouvement grandissant,
qui s'élèverait de la terre, et irait vers la lumière,
et deviendrait solide, exactement comme un arbre. Merci.